Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing
where we left off with regards to
the story
of the prophet sallall.aii wasallam's
first
reception
of revelation from Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
Revelation
is a very strenuous
process.
It is not easy. It's not simple. It has
physiological effects
and it has
emotional and
psychological stresses that are involved
in the process.
We are speaking about
the words of Allah Almighty, the divine,
the sublime,
the endless,
the infinite,
the unique.
He is taking his words
and putting them into the heart of a
human being.
This is not a simple process.
Allah Subhanahu Waaala says to the
prophet Sam,
he said indeed we are going to send down
upon you a very heavy and lofty and
grave speech and revelation.
Notice the words that were used here.
In the Arabic language
can be used to articulate something that
is physically heavy.
Can be used to articulate some or to
describe something that is grave and
weighty.
And both are intended here in this
verse.
Zabat
and Bkari
said that
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
received revelation
while I was sitting next to him. Zenit
is one of the scribes of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. when revelation
would come or they were anticipating
revelation,
he would call for zade and summon him.
He would come, he would bring his pen,
he would bring his slates, whatever they
were, and he would wait to write
whatever new verses the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam
recites to him. And so as they were
waiting, he was sitting next to the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
this sitting next to each other a
kimbo. And he said the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam's thigh was on my
thigh.
Right? If you could imagine that we're
sitting cross-legged
next to each other. His thigh was on
mine. They were very close to each
other. He said when revelation suddenly
came.
He said and I felt the physical weight
of his body become heavy.
So heavy that I thought my thigh was
going to smash. It was going to burst
from the weight of his thigh just
sitting on mine. From the revelation
in
a sunin
it's mentioned that the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam was riding
on his camel in Mecca when he received
the chapter of al- Mida. Al- Mida is one
of the last chapters of the Quran to be
revealed to the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. It was revealed to him in
Mecca during
he was on his camel and he was being led
during when
was revealed to him. The companion said
that the camel started to buckle under
the weight of the revelation.
It almost collapsed under the weight of
the revelation. The prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam had to get down off of
the camel before it broke the camel's
legs because of the weight. This is a
physical weight that these words would
bring.
Not to mention the gravity
of the words of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
And so
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
And so this revelation is not easy. The
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam had to
have a preface to prepare his heart for
this revelation. That preparation came
in the form of a few months. Some
scholars posit that it is about 6 months
of premonitions that he would have in
his sleep. Sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
He'd wake up and he would see exactly
vividly, word for word, movement for
movement, action for action, moment for
moment, what he saw in his premonition,
in his sleep play out in the real world,
in his wake.
And so this continued on for a number of
months.
Says, forch.
[Silence]
He says, she says,
she said after this time passed by of
these premonitions that he was
getting, we said if the premonitions
were 6 months, right? This would mean
that if the first revelation of the
Quran came in what month?
the month of Ramadan. And so the month
of Ramadan is what number? No. Number
nine, right? 6 months before that.
What's the third month?
What's
interesting about
that's the month that he was born in.
That's the month that it said that's the
month that he received revelation in.
The prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
would have first began receiving or
having these premonitions during that
month. Then later
in the month of Ramadan
during that month he started to go to
the mountain the cave of
and he would stay there
said
he would go to
and he would worship Allah there.
worship Allah doing what? What what was
his worship
at this point? Does he is he making
salah? Is he making
what is his worship that she's speaking
about that he would go to and make
there?
Anyone have an idea?
[Arabic recitation]
You know the word meditation is an
interesting word. It's been hijacked by
the wrong folks. Meditation really means
to what? To contemplate. I mean sah is
meditation. But then when you say
meditation what pops into your mind
immediately? The Buddhist guy sitting in
his red whatever you know Harry Krishna
chanting some shivi yet. Right. So the
problem is is that the word meditation
has become hijacked and also by soccer
moms. Soccer moms to do meditation,
you know, cuz they were they saw it on
on Tik Tok, right? They saw it on
Instagram. You got to say you got to
focus on your breathing. You got Muslims
doing this at the same time, right?
Muslims yes, mindfulness, 5
minutes of mindfulness in the what is
for? What is mindfulness? They have
nothing to think about. So the idea is
I'm going to sit and think about
absolutely nothing as best as I can.
That's the point of meditation in most
popular of Eastern religions and
disciplines Buddhism and right
that's the idea. You think about
nothing. If you must think about
something think about your breathing.
That's it. Only think about your
breathing. Just think when you breathe
in and breathe out. That's it. clear
your mind completely right and then you
feel better. This is
we get to think about Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala and contemplate his names and
attributes and they get to think about
their breathing.
The point here is that he would it was
not meditation it was contemplation.
When she says,
she means that he would go to that cave
and contemplate. He would look at the
stars. He would look at the moon. He
would think. He would think and reflect
on why am I here? Why do I exist? Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Why did he create
me? Why are my people worshiping idols?
Where did this come from? What is the
religion of Ibraim truly? I wish I knew.
I wish I understood these things.
This time of absence when the questions
flared up. This was the perfect time for
the first revelation to come to the
prophet sallall.aii.
So this here that she's speaking about
is
Oh Allah, you didn't create this for no
good reason. Then what is the reason?
Guide me. You created me. Guide me. Tell
me what to do. I'll do anything.
And so
said that he would go there for nights
on end. And he would actually not want
to break his reflection and
contemplation
even to go get food. So he would take
food with him for a number of nights. He
would go there and stay away from
everyone.
He started to desire and be more
inclined towards solitude
said.
And so he would start to go to this cave
in because it's of its high place and
because it was you know out of the
way it's less likely someone's going to
pass by and find him there. If anybody
here has ever been to Omrah and you've
seen it's very steep and awkward and
out of the way. It's very small. No
one's going to go there unless they're
going for that cave specifically. And
that's why he chose that cave sai
wasallam. And so he would go there for a
number of nights. When he'd run out of
food, he would come back to Khadijah.
She would pack him a new ration for
however many nights and he would go back
for another span of evenings
there. She said,
And he continued to do this until the
truth meaning revelation finally came to
him while he was in the cave in saiam.
Now I want you to imagine with me
when you read the Quran how do we make
the Quran affect us? How does it change
us? You know when you just read the
Quran with the foremost of your mind and
you leave away the deep contemplation
and you take its details for granted.
When you read about Mus Alisam when he
was lost with his family on his way back
to Egypt, you need to be standing there
with Mus Alisam.
You need to feel his anxiety. You need
to feel his bewilderment when he went up
onto that tree that found it was
resonating light and Allah spoke to him
and said, "Yeah."
He said, "Oh M, indeed it is I, Allah,
none is rightfully worship but I."
You're supposed to be there standing
there with him. When you read these
stories, you need to envision these
things as deeply as possible in order
for these things to affect your heart,
to change, to come into your your mind
and and to replace the filth that the
dunya puts into our heart and replace it
with the light.
What is the setting? We have the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam in this cave. We
know for a fact it's night time. It's
nighttime because Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala tells us what.
So it's night for sure. And there may
have been a small fire. We know it was
at the end of Ramadan.
So in the last 10 nights and so was the
moon out. Was it very bright? No. The
moon would have been very slight, very
small. It would not have been bright.
Pitch black, total darkness.
Everyone is asleep. There's no one out.
When suddenly, as the prophet
sallallah.aii Wasam is sitting there up
in this cave in the middle of nowhere
all the way at the top of this obscure
mountain in this obscure little tiny
cave.
Somebody approaches him. It's a man who
approaches him. He's never seen this man
before. He doesn't recognize this man.
And this man walks up to him. Doesn't
say a single word.
All he did was come very close, very
close enough to touch him
and he says
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam is
captivated by this who is this so many
questions
and so the only response he has is
meaning I don't know how to read. Now
the word in Arabic has a dual meaning.
Based on context, we know what it means,
right? So for instance, if there's
something written
means read this written thing, but if
there's nothing written could also mean
recite.
Here the context is unclear.
It's not as some have mentioned that he
had some piece of paper and he said to
him, and he presented him with it.
That's there's no authentic narrations
mentioning that rather he's just saying
to him
read what he understands as read. So
he's responding to the question.
He says,
he said, "So when I said to the man, I
am illiterate. I'm unable to read."
The man took me
and squeezed me so hard until I was
breathless. He couldn't breathe anymore.
And just as I, you know, just as he had,
I had reached my limits and felt he
was going to pass out, he let me go. And
he said again,
imagine the bewilderment here, the
emotions, what do you want from me?
He said when I said this to him again,
I'm unable to read. He took me a second
time and squeezed me so tight that I was
breathless
until finally he released me and he said
to me a third time.
So now he had grabbed him three times.
You notice the number three comes up a
lot in Islam, in our religion, even in
the natural world, even in logic. The
number three comes up a lot. Why? Once
is a coincidence, right? Once is a
fluke, an off thing. It's an occurrence.
Twice is a coincidence. Three times
articulates habits.
Always. Three times articulates habit.
Right? And so when he took him this
third time
and he squeezed him that third time,
Jirel released him and said
Jirel wasn't saying wasn't commanding
him with anything. He was delivering a
message. It sounded he was
commanding him with something, but he
wasn't. He was actually reciting to him,
but he didn't understand that yet.
He said
[Silence]
and then he turned around and left. He
disappeared into the night.
That's the entire
occurrence. How long did that take? At
most a minute or two.
How bewildered
was the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
upon hearing such eloquence,
such violence,
such gentleness,
such harshness, such enlightenment.
So many questions but so much
information.
It is a very
starkly contrasting set of events that
are jarring and it's meant to be
jarring. It wasn't meant to be a nice
feeling. It wasn't supposed to have a
warm fuzzy feeling he was supposed to be
left with. It was designed to scare him
at first. Sallallah.aii wasallam. Take
that, compare it. Is this how Allah
usually reaches out to the prophets and
messengers? What is the first command
Allah gave to Musam?
What's the first command?
Right? Throw your stick down. The stick
turned into
a giant snake that moved in an
unnaturally
fast pace.
So, it's a huge snake. It should be
moving slowly. Instead, it's whipping
around and moving in an unnatural way.
What was the second command he gave him?
No, what is it?
But with regards to the stick,
the second thing was immediately take
it. Reach out and take it. Right? Why
did he have to go through that before he
was given the light?
Now, think about this. First, throw the
stick down. Now, he's terrified.
As a matter of fact, he was so scared.
He ran away so fast he didn't even
glance back. He was out of there.
The next thing,
no, no, come back.
Reach down and pick it up. Now I mean
the horror of such a thing and the snake
the significance is a natural predator.
It's a natural phobia that humans have.
99.9%
of humanity is naturally afraid of
snakes even as babies. People are scared
of snakes, right? But no, that's the
first lesson. You have to reach out and
grab it. You have to be very scared
first.
And then you have to conquer that fear.
You have to conquer that fear and trust
me more than you trust your eyes, more
than you trust your ears, more than you
trust your body. Then we're ready for
the next lesson. That has to happen
first. Reach out and grab it. The
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam's
first meeting with Gibl was not
pleasant.
It was terrifying.
It was so terrifying that he couldn't
speak
and he was shaking and shivering in one
narration.
His heart of hearts was shivering in
fear.
This here is where we will stop for
tonight. We've gone way far beyond our
time. only because we're telling a
story. If this was some kind of aam or
something, people would be like, ",
she what's going on? We got to go home."
But we will stop here for tonight.
Inshallah, we'll pick this up again
tomorrow.
Alhamdulillah.